waouh
vous êtes nombreux vous êtes attentif et
en plus ils ont été bons
à part ça j'ai pas la pression je vais
vous parler de certaines expériences que
j'ai pu vivre que j'ai pu voir ici vous
voyez ce que je fais aujourd'hui j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire doute métier
auparavant dans ce cadre là j'ai eu
quelques expériences
je me rappelle notamment ce coup de fil
j'ai reçu un dimanche
fin juillet c'était pierre pierre me dit
au téléphone
écoute ta vie de j'ai besoin de toi il
faut absolument que tu dis ben des
publie un article sur un de nos sites
web et pierre ont dès dimanche ça peut
pas attendre de ben écoute david c'est
pas possible il ya un journaliste qui a
fait une erreur et sur un article qui
doit parler des bouchons des départs en
vacances
il a mis en ligne une vidéo et cette
vidéo il s'agit de terroristes qui
martyrise des otages je dis waouh
effectivement c'est embêtant mais je
peux pas t'en occuper écoute ma ville je
suis sur la route je suis avec les
enfants la bagnole est plein je peux pas
me connecter c'est pas possible il faut
que tu fasses quelque chose on va
écouter julien mais le journaliste en
question l'a ainsi vient de faire
l'erreur il peut pas s'en occuper
écoute david je te dire un truc sept
gardiens qui m'a appelé le journaliste
qu'on s'est rendu compte de son erreur
il est tombé dans les pommes
dimanche 7 mai 2017
j'arrive sur les bureaux de l'équipe
numérique de france des infos moi je
dois intervenir
je dois surveiller ce qui se passe sur
les réseaux sociaux suit un logiciel qui
a développé mon équipe depuis le matin
les équipes techniques la rive tout le
monde répète tout se passe bien
les premiers résultats de sondages
arrive là et un petit problème de
de format dans les fichiers je sens
l'équipe de gauche qui commencent à
travailler qui évidemment va en créer ok
c'est bon c'est ajusté 19h55 résultats
dans cinq minutes
19h58 résultats dans deux minutes
5 4 3 2 1
bougez résultat si si ça s'est bien
passé
vous avez cru que un autre exemple un
peu plus récents je reçois un coup de
fil au bureau informaticiens me précise
qu'un de ses collaborateurs n'accepte
plus à ses fichiers
je suis dit mais qu'est ce qui se passe
il m'a écouté comprend pas tous les noms
de fichiers ont changé ils s'appellent
tous - maintenant points block point
elle au setca
aïe inquiétude dans l'équipe
pourquoi c'est sûrement un crypto locker
qui à crypter les fichiers
la phase suivante c'est quoi c'est un
pirate qui va demander une rançon pour
que les fichiers puisse être
réutilisables là au sein de l'équipe
la pression commence à monter moi je
commence à avoir chaud comme maintenant
j'ai les mains qui se refroidissent
comme maintenant et là chacun y va de sa
suggestion il y en a un qui dit écoute
david e je vais regarder dans les mails
pour voir quel type de message cette
personne a reçu il y en a un autre qui
dit waouh pour la prévenir la dg parce
que ça peut être chaud là maintenant un
troisième qui dit un peu dépité encore
nimbé singh qu'à cliquer sur n'importe
quoi y'en a marre là je me dis c'est
inquiétant on risque de disperser mais
c'est ma première expérience dans ce
genre de dans ce genre de cas je prend
une grande respiration je me dis mon
avis qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
il ya plusieurs idées faut s'organiser
je me mets au paperboard je lis les
actions à réaliser et on serait répartie
et c'est parti là aussi je vous assure
tout s'est bien terminé
là j'ai visité un certain nombre de
situations dans un premier quart une
situation inattendue qui mène à la perte
de contrôle
le journaliste est tombé dans les pommes
dans le deuxième cas un imprévu mais une
situation répétait depuis des mois des
choses qui sont maîtrisés et finalement
en imprévus permet d'être gérés et
l'objectif à atteindre sans encombre
dans le dernier cas celui sur lequel
j'étais un peu plus impliqués là un
moment il faut se dire bon on se
reconcentre il faut définir ce qu'il ya
à faire en revient aux primordiaux tout
ça pour vous expliquer que les types de
réactions peuvent être différents dans
les réactions je dirais avec une
connotation plutôt plutôt négative
on peut avoir l'effet syncope la
sidération déjà vu entendu quelques
quelques exemples on peut avoir des gens
qui ont au contraire vont fuir la
situation vont sont allés vont
disparaître dans des situations de
pression vous pouvez avoir des gens qui
vont avoir une certaine agitation
motrices je sais pas si vous avez pu
observer les intervenants certains qui
ont marché de cette façon là tout le
temps pendant la présentation d'autres
qui sont revenus à leurs fondamentaux
le chef d'orchestre qui s'est plutôt
balancer comme ça un petit peu pour
retrouver ses habitudes et se rassurer
avec la mesure vous avez d'autres qui
vont avoir aussi une conduite
automatique réflexe un exemple j'ai vécu
sur un incident de sécurité
oui effectivement on avait besoin que
tout le monde soit mobilisé en fait une
des personnes à continuer à lire
automatiquement ses mails pour
s'échapper revenir à des automatismes
dans le cadre de cette situation vous
voir des réactions un peu plus positive
certains les ont évoqué finalement la
pression c'est top
ça donne de l'énergie ça permet
d'avancer ça donne envie
vous pouvez avoir dans le cadre de
réactions positives
c'est ce qu'on va appeler finalement dé
la répétition de protocole on s'est
préparé on sait qu'on a la pression mais
on sait qu'on doit respecter le
protocole alors ça devient un
automatisme positif parce qu'on fait on
fait ce qu'il faut
je pense que c'est le cas dans le milieu
médical dans le milieu de la
cybersécurité aussi c'est des choses
qu'on essaye de faire on fait de la
gestion de crise on essaye de répéter de
de s'entraîner en fait ce qu'il faut
retenir et ç'a déjà été évoqué c'est que
chaque l'un vit la pression suivant sa
personnalité suivant la situation
suivant l'impact est l'enjeu pour lui
même et son environnement
il n'y a pas besoin d'être médecin pour
vivre la pression il n'y a pas besoin de
sauter en parachute pour vivre la
pression tout le monde peut se trouver
dans une citation pression vous aussi
vous êtes trouver dans des situations de
pression
vous avez passé des examens vous avez
passé des concours
vous avez participé à des campagnes de
liste n'est ce pas ça c'était y'a pas
longtemps c'est très récent encore dans
le cadre de situations que j'ai pu vivre
moi aussi je me rappelle d'une d'une
démonstration que j'avais à faire sur un
salon c'était au salon de l'éducation
nationale et en présenter une offre de
vidéos éducatives à la mode sur internet
la pression elle était là parce que
finalement c'était l'aboutissement du
travail de toute une équipe
depuis depuis plus d'un an c'était la
première présentation sur un stand avec
des invités et le ministre de
l'éducation nationale lui même assisté à
cette première présentation
donc oui là aussi j'avais la
présentation comme chez dit tout à
l'heure
j'avais chaud j'avais les mains froides
comme d'hab
et là je me suis dit mais qu'est ce que
je vais faire j'ai pris une bonne
respiration et je me suis raccroché à ce
que j'avais préparé à montech ce que
j'avais en tête au papier que j'avais
sous la main comme aujourd'hui l'ue dans
le cadre de situations de pression
finalement il ya des pressions qu'on
peut s'inventer qui vont disparaître
par exemple je joue au tennis je me suis
inscrit dans un certain nombre de
compétitions je fais un peu de
compétition par équipes ont assuré vous
vous me verrez jamais à roland garros je
me souviens l'année dernière d'un match
que je devais jouer contre quelqu'un qui
était bien plus fort que moi
en fait là je me suis pas du tout mis la
pression je savais que de toute façon
c'était perdu d'avancé
j'y suis allé je me suis dit ben david
tu risque rien toute façon tu vas perdre
ton gaz il joue non j'ai pas gagné j'ai
pas gagné désolé mais par contre j'étais
pas mécontent de moi et j'avais fait un
bon match
autre situation c'est au début de vos
début de ma carrière j'ai commencé en
régie finale au sein d'une télévision
qui veut net se monte donc la chaîne
était toute nouvelle gt en régie finale
et nous étions trois équipes de trois
personnes pour assurer la diffusion de
5h30 du matin à minuit le soir nous
étions trois équipes de trois personnes
mais nous sachions manifestement qu'au
bout de trois mois
nous ne saurions que trois équipes de
deux personnes
concrètement on avait tous la pression
là aussi j'avais la pression comment
j'ai fait moi je me suis dit daly il
faut y aller c'est la chance d'avoir ton
job à la télé ce dont tu rêvais dans ce
cadre là tu bosses donc j'ai potassé les
dogues j'ai potassé les procédures pour
être très et savoir gérer à tout moment
quelques conseils concrets sur comment
gérer la pression
gb raisonnée temporellement avant
pendant après avant il est important que
vous vous connaissiez que vous
identifiez vos propres signe de réaction
à la pression que vous identifier quand
vous devez quand vous passez sous
pression vous vous identifiez quand vous
atteignez la limite qui va faire que
vous risquez de vous sentir mal avant ce
qui là aussi important de se préparer on
va parler de répétition vous avez répété
la présentation on l'a tous oui ça
permet de se sentir plus à l'aise
enfin normalement cette préparation est
importante
moi je sais que j'ai plutôt l'habitude
de d'anticiper de projeter de me dire
mais qu'est ce qui va se passer comment
je vais le vivre d'imaginer donc j'étais
très content d'avoir vu une photo de
l'amphi
quand j'ai pu préparer cette
intervention un moment je sais que quand
j'étais au numérique
j'aimais beaucoup prévoir la catastrophe
donc je demande est constamment mes
équipes de préparer quelque chose
un plan b mon début ça les agace est et
puis après ils ont rigolé puis mon petit
surnom c'est un moment ça a été monsieur
plan b cependant il est important de
savoir observer pouvoir ce qui se passe
voir comment vous réagissez
si vous commencez à être pas bien si
votre esprit commença à s'embrouiller
dans le cas d'une situation pression il
est un il est importante je dirais de de
prendre un peu de recul on pouvait le
faire différentes façons pouvez vous
poser prendre une grande respiration
c'est important de vous et oxygénées
l'esprit d'oxygéner le corps vous pouvez
bouger sortir vous pouvez aussi observer
ce qui se passe chez les autres
vous pouvez avoir l'attitude de la
personne qui va être sous pression qui
va se mettre à taper du pied
vous pouvez avoir l'attitude de la
personne qui va se mettre
à taper des doigts sur la table je suis
sûr qu'il y en a beaucoup d'entre vous
qui ont l'habitude de jouer avec leurs
stylos de faire tourner leur style
autour de leurs doigts
c'est peut-être un signe chez vous 2 de
pression de sensibilité à la pression il
faut réagir aussi face à cette situation
là pour éventuellement sortir quelqu'un
de la réunion si c'est une réunion de
crise par exemple le risque c'est
d'avoir finalement des gens qui vont
nuire à la réaction s'ils ne sont pas à
même de faire face à la pression
c'est pour ça identifier les signes
identifier ce qui ce qui se passe
éventuellement aider la personne à
prendre du recul ça peut être très
simple quand vous identifier cette
personne à qui n'est plus en mesure de
réagir d'être dans l'action vous la
sortez du groupe vous l'emmenez vous
essayer de la faire parler ou d'essayer
de comprendre ce qui se passe c'est un
moyen pour être finalement
d'extérioriser et vous pouvez vérifier
ses dents capacité de retourner pour
traiter les choses qu'elle a à faire et
si c'est pas le cas il faut vous poser
la question est ce que finalement c'est
pas mieux que cette personne je la sorte
du groupe et risquent elles risquent de
nuire dans des situations vous allez
rencontrer aussi vous allez avoir des
rendez vous avec vos managers
vous allez aussi est manager vous même
donc il est intéressant dans le cadre
des entretiens que vous pourrez avoir
avec avec vos collaborateurs
d'identifier à quel moment vous sentez
qu'il commence à être un petit peu sous
pression
et là c'est important de les faire
parler leur faire dire bah écoute joie
que là quelque chose qui va pas il ya
quelque chose que tu as va être pas à
gérer tu as besoin d aide après il est
aussi intéressant de décompresser après
la situation en pression on respire on
peut se dire ça y est c'est bon c'est
passé mais c'est intéressant d'aller au
delà dans des cadres de réaction il ya
des choses qu'on
eh bien il ya des choses qu'on fait mal
il ya des choses qu'on peut mieux faire
c'est super intéressant et important de
débriefer c'est-à-dire examinent
ensemble comment on peut mieux faire la
prochaine fois c'est comme ça qu'on
progresse et c'est comme ça qu'on saura
mieux gérer et qu'on peut être amené
également à mieux faire face à la
pression
après il ya autre chose qui est
important si ça s'est bien passé et puis
si tout le monde est d'accord c'est
fêter mais ça je sais que faire la fête
vous savez faire ça aussi enfin il me
reste quelques minutes
je voudrais profiter de ce moment pour
faire une une petite expérience je vais
appeler à me rejoindre
un première année je vais appeler un
garçon un garçon dont le prénom commence
par la lettre b
non non rassurez vous je vais faire
venir personne
ce qui m'intéresse là c'est finalement
que vous vous demandiez comment chacun
de vous a réagi j'ai vu derrière j'ai vu
des têtes se tournent et je suis sûr
qu'il y en a certains qui sont enfoncés
dans leurs fauteuils et qui ont commencé
à regarder leurs pieds il y en a
d'autres qui intérieurement au contraire
ont dû se relever dans leurs fauteuils
et se dire ouais moi moi moi je vais y
aller il y en a même un qui s'est levé
on nous avait qu'à voir
donc voilà tout ça pour vous permettre
de vous poser des questions et de vous
dire ben moi comment je réagis à la
pression et identifier les premiers
signes enfin pour terminer une petite
phrase qui peut servir de conseil je
vous invite à lire cette phrase je vous
en reparle après
surprenant en fait ce qui est important
là c'est que lorsque vous trouvez dans
un entretien qui a un enjeu énorme pour
vous quand vous êtes face à quelqu'un
qui vous impressionne de folie et par
penser à cette phrase et je pense que ça
va vous aider à vous apaiser et assurer
votre entretien à l'autre présentation
merci
[Applaudissements]